you know who's doing it right Kurt  Russell and Goldie Hawn they've been  together for 32 years and they're not  married they have a kid together on a  house together it's perfect think about  that for a second a 32 year relationship  when divorce rates are at an all-time  high  so fellas maybe you don't have to lock  it down and spend an insane amount of  money on a stone and piece of metal and  even insane our amount of money on a  giant party for other people and the  insane is the amount of money on  attorney fees take a script from old  curtain Goldie less is way way more you  know who's doing it right yoga  nobody talks nobody complains you never  have to hear that meathead in the  background groaning